[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Let's Get Married
oh no no no I love that song
Friday the 13th we're getting married
the 14th 13th or 14th we're getting
divorced
weekend it's gonna be crazy but one day
I'll finally enjoy uh my trip to Earth
you guys welcome back to the break room
Our Daily Show that keeps you updated on
all the nerdy news you need to know
about coming up James Cameron is off the
deep end which you know he's always been
he's always been you know he's always
been Echo has been delayed which sucks
shuri's original black panther role and
James Gunn presents his DC plans because
this is the week where all the the
secrets come out
speaking of Secrets
this is Erica
no secret here yeah hello Internet good
to see y'all
introduced it was Erica many times his
first name's Adam
yes Adam last name oh wow I'm Adam black
oh and in the phone book you are yeah
to my right is uh I'm not gonna make a
black Tommy joke
[Applause]
and let's make it the most problematic
one yet chat your your garbage I don't
like you dispose of yourself throw
yourself away maybe in 2023 some of you
will crawl out of the landfill and
become like a little tulip Blossom
growing from from the cracks of trash
like Wally yeah
you're all the Wally planet to me you're
the you're the nuclear Wasteland I have
to tolerate you to have a job but just
know every second I'm with you is pure
torture God to my right
uh Tommy's right the only other person
in this office that I can't stand
because you dress better than me
something really nice and I'm like damn
I'm always trying to keep up with it
again
oh yeah this is the 90s like team I had
this for seven years I love this so much
this is OG box lunch like you know like
box lunch every season they spice it up
a little bit this is seven years box
lunch seven years I'm loyal I gotta go
to eBay maybe and get out yeah for one
of those I think uh anything I wore
eight years ago will not fit me today
I'm doing broccoli chicken in 2023 guys
if you want to lose weight with me
hashtag Tommy too tiny
that hashtag will be ignored by Me by
the way so if you use it like all of
your messages online I'll simply ignore
them oh my God speaking of tiny it's
over headlines they're not tiny today we
have a lot
we have a ton of headlines starting with
James Gunn and Peter saffron are set to
present their plans for the DCU this
week a lot of info in the media has been
tossed around over the last few days so
we did our best to separate fact from
fiction and give you the details so
let's get I guess let's try to get in
this okay last week after the news of
Wonder Woman 3's cancellation The
Hollywood Reporter detailed that it was
Patty Jenkins decision to walk away from
the project after she was unwilling to
make necessary changes since she's
released a statement saying it was my
understanding that there was nothing I
could do to move forward anything
forward at this time look at this day I
trust her I do too I think you know
a it's a saucy story to say that the
person who kind of created the world the
current iteration the world of Wonder
Woman that we have on screen was like
I'm gone you won't do it my way I'm out
of here but I don't know she's got a
career spanning a long time in Hollywood
there are difficult directors we're
about to talk to about one of the most
difficult directors of all time later
but I mean it tends to be a town that's
very unfair to women and like if women
show any kind of attitude they're
labeled as difficult to work with and
blackballed so it's like I don't know
she goes from franchise to franchise and
people seem to love her so I I just does
great work yeah it's all it's not like
she's needing this right I'm not worried
about that she'll be fine that contrast
just to Echo it that contrast of what
we're going to get into of like James
Cameron yes and what he says and does
his movies will never get like
on camera this is conjecture versus on
camera oh yeah and what I want to lead
off with this discussion with is that
we've seen a lot of shared universes
start this is unprecedented we're about
to see how you end a shared universe and
I think that's really interesting so all
of these articles coming out all of this
conjecture James Gunn keeps
systematically being like nope nope nope
everyone's making stuff up because it's
Saucy it's a headline it's exciting I
think this is we always talk about how
dangerous clickbait is we always talk
about how dangerous it is all this
negativity we're seeing for the first
time someone in the position of power
actually coming out and being like no
shut up and I love that because he's
doing an unprecedented thing he has to
stop something and restart something
Kevin feige for all of his power has
never had to come out and be like stop
lying because because that's already
moving you know what I mean this is a
very new thing the thing is it's also
like how easy is it once the the box has
been opened you know after that
information got out everyone went with
it in different directions so it's like
it's hard to put that back in the box so
they're going to try to make these two
people look like they're villains and
hate each other and they don't they're
just like this is not how we're just not
gonna tell you right the audience
everything we're doing James dem's first
phone call is to Kevin feige like when
he got like they talked about that job
like they talked about that like all
these rivalries are made manufactured by
the fans I'm sure Patty Jenkins left
amicably until someone heard about it
then all of a sudden it was like they
hate each other and now she has to make
a press release she should never have to
make I think the dangers of the type of
Journalism that a lot of YouTube is that
we avoid consciously is this thing we
like you she shouldn't have to come out
and be like that's not true here's a
novel yeah and Patty with her statement
she said she's working on Rogue Squadron
yeah it's in development yeah and
Hollywood behind the scenes is very
tricky stuff goes it doesn't stuff's
happening it's not and it's easier to
for me to believe that Patty Jenkins
amicably left this project or it just
didn't work out and they were like
thanks but no thanks then to believe
that Warner Brothers is completely
innocent when Warner Brothers is
literally gutting itself because you
Discovery merger they got rid of the
Batgirl movie yesterday Westworld
yesterday yeah so like I I'm on team
Patty with this I hope I wish all the
best for her and yeah I hope Wonder
Woman continues in some way shape or
forms I agree and I think to your point
there is also a chance James Gunn is
just kind of stepping in front of him
being a shield for Warner Brothers
because he knows he has to kind of deal
with what's left over after zazlov and
and Co chop everything up so maybe like
it was like James Gunn made creative
notes Patty Jenkins didn't like them was
like the story he's like fine if that's
what people want to run with that like I
was the one who said it it might have
just been zazzloff being like we're
gonna face out all of these existing
Snyder verse characters and you know
unfortunately Patty Jenkins had created
a character within the sniper so
collateral damage if you will there's
also nothing intuitive about this that's
what's been so interesting is nothing
makes sense yet yeah so Aquaman coming
out later maybe and like they they put
all that money they're gonna do it but
we now we've heard Ben Affleck's in it
he's not in it like there's nothing
logic based so you can write any article
you want you can literally post a photo
write a white text over it little Trend
right I think the we should do that yeah
I think the best takeaway was James gun
which is I love how open he is about it
he doesn't need to be but I like that
James Gunn was like the only people that
know what's happening is me and Peter
saffron uh line of demise sent in a
Super Chat they need to do a DC fandom
it will solve so many questions yes I
don't know if it will it will also raise
a lot of questions for the people behind
the scenes sure I think they're trying
to settle everything before they can
come back and do like all right DC
fandom though would be a great way to
relaunch the brand you know like once
they're ready
give us some graphics also I've never
been more excited for a San Diego
Comic-Con this year is going to be so
insane I missed the last two baby I'm
gonna be back Gaslamp District
board up the doors
the hurricane Bechtel is predicted to be
there for five days and it will cause a
lot of damage what are you gonna dress
up as well
I dress up as guy who got into the
industry party where there's an open bar
that I dress up as hungover guy at the
Starbucks the next day regretting his
life then I'd stop it I regret this is
why we're not gonna get no no it started
talking tom
what did it say we all saw it what did
it say Alexa sorry I didn't hear you
what did you say wrong device name what
did you say to me Alexa
what did you say to me hahaha
all right John's gonna be mad but but uh
Eric also noticed that either way we'll
go back on
Seth Belgian listen I had my onboarding
meeting today and you can't touch me
like that wouldn't this be an official
Complaint you guys he bit me he bit me
you mentioned the Gaslamp district and
he's gaslighting us yes so it's not that
bad in here either way blink if you need
help
um so so like why said earlier about
James Gunn responding to the Tweet he
did quote tweet Patty and was like uh I
can attest that all P all of Peter and
my interactions with you were only
Pleasant and professional I love that
classic also doesn't have to do any of
this I love that James Gunn is spending
his time being like this is ridiculous I
think it's because he's just so used to
the fans that he's just genuinely like
you guys don't need to attack this
person and it also creates a non-toxic
working environment and what a
refreshing thing that would be in in
Hollywood speaking of non-toxic shout
out to Johnny dashel for bringing the
receipt graphics on the show today we've
got tweets we've got statements they are
on it work everybody this show is tight
Anna kudos to Eric because you mentioned
this earlier and we're going to come
back here right now uh good job also in
uh Patty's statement she announced that
her Star Wars movie Rogue Squadron is
back an active development this film
joins Kevin feige Michael Waldron's film
Damon lindelhoff's film and tiger
watiti's film as active development Star
Wars movies I'm ready are we ready I'm
ready I think iger's going to really
focus up on the theatrical Star Wars
like he's like let's get back in
theaters let's get Parks back to being
priceable like let's let's do this I'm
really excited for this I am I I'm so
excited about the parks but I'm also
excited for Star Wars because I feel
like we talked about this last week when
we did Red Flag green flag for like the
Star Wars universe and I was like this
year it wasn't hitting right for me and
maybe next year it I think these
properties can and I really want Rogue
Squadron to get me also an avatar seeing
a movie of that scale in the theater it
reminds me of like non-marvel movies
like it's good to be in a theater and
watch like a Sci-Fi like a different
kind of iPhone nice to have some
competition it's not entire monopolies I
don't know yes
yes that is 100 true and I also say
Rogue Squadron if you're looking for a
beautiful diverse talented cast look
different than the four of us is the
Rogue Squad right here
red leader standing by uh you're uh the
princess but you are in Disguise as a
Rogue Squadron pilot
and then your plane gets a little winged
your your ex-wing gets are not X-Wing
yeah your X-Wing gets a little winged
and then then koi who knows the secret
goes then she's royalty
I trust him in space even though there's
no gravity you jump out and there's
gravity just in that one little point
and I catch you and I say let's get
married and she says I know quoting Han
Solo this is a sequel anyway uh back in
reality yeah back to reality and there
goes gravity and non Wonder Woman news
gun did tweet that Superman is perhaps
the Studio's biggest priority and
followed that up by saying Green Lantern
is also important Green Lantern the
Green Lantern I would be so so I love
the Green Lantern when I was gonna make
the same movie two aliens well no green
light what are you about to say I what
are you about this I have said had four
months okay that I think that the Batman
we have in Matt Reeves Universe should
say separate did you see the deck today
yeah I was no no I thought he wanted to
work no James gunson is not that
happened this morning today this morning
today
and then James Gunn was like nope which
is like again he didn't have to do that
he didn't have to do that for us so I'm
excited that thank you John look up with
the quickness yeah so I love not only
does he credit the author saying they're
a good guy so so as to not be
disparaging the writer but also it
doesn't make sense to have this Batman
this Gotham they just built to be
intentionally separate somehow now fold
in I don't want to see a Superman of any
kind mix with that right here
100 because they grounded it so
consciously if you throw in an alien
there's a reason no one's Batman's
didn't have the greater DC Universe I
think they should talk over there have a
second Batman whoever you want put it in
Justice League but I don't think a
Batman we currently have works with the
Green Lantern that's what made me I have
that thought as like the Green Lantern
Matt Reeves yeah like no no no you can't
have a space cop but what are you gonna
say about Matt Reeves and the Joker so I
don't don't think the Joker should be
tied to anything I think they should not
consciously have a DC Black Label where
they can make elseworld stuff and that
way you can tell the more advantageous
stories for directors and that way
directors can have their freedom outside
of the shared universe and that would
actually make them stronger than Marvel
yeah I think one of Marvel's biggest
flaws right now is everyone's looking
for Easter eggs and tie-ins to the point
that directors feel like they're chained
I think the reason these special
editions are doing so much better than
the shows is the special editions feel
like they don't have to be able to hold
in this stuff so if you let a dark
universe exist separate of stuff it's
like your special editions kind of
flavor and people aren't as dumb to
think that one Batman has to exist
anymore we've been used to this now for
a while well this is what I'm gonna ask
and I'm asking this to the entire table
uh I guess it's kind of like similar to
how we think about uh across the spider
verse with Miles Morales to our Tom
Holland Spiderman yeah it's like do you
think they have to acknowledge each
other exists not the characters but the
properties so it's like James Gunn is
going to acknowledge that Matt Reeves is
doing the Batman and what if he makes
like a prime villain his prime villain
and then also in the DC they want to
pull that same thing right see I think
as long as there's different casts like
I don't honestly think you know Brendan
Gleason might be playing the penguin
right that doesn't exclude Colin
Farrell's Penguins yeah ironically both
in uh banshees of insurance available
today in HBO Max
I love that movie so much but like I
love the idea of there being the
audience being trusted enough to have
these universes exist separately because
the comics trust us enough like when I
pick up a Batman comic I'm not like
we're Superman because I know there's
five Batman comics what is Brandon
Gleason rumor to be uh penguin he's in
Joker he's in Joker yeah Joker too
right so that's exciting and what you're
saying makes sense too because in The
Hollywood Reporter variety articles I'm
reading about James Gunn and everyone's
taking over
the the main issue they're having is
okay they know they're coming in and
starting a whole new era of dceu movies
hopefully starting in 2024 going forward
so they don't want to say all right
flash uh Aquaman Blue Beetle and
whatever else is coming out next year
are it for Snyder verse or whatever
everything else that's been and then
we're starting new stuff because it's
like they don't want to say we're
getting everybody else stuff we're
starting new stuff so they have to
figure out ways to squash these bad
rumors right keep interest in the stuff
that is coming out in 2023 because they
got money to make yeah and then it kind
of seamlessly start developing and
rolling out that's something we've never
seen before yeah we've never seen the
universe end yeah so it's also
interesting because you look at what the
climates become with shows that get
canceled people are like oh it's only
one season I'm out watching and that's
so weird and short-sighted what if
that's your favorite season of TV ever
when shows get canceled the viewership
drops so they're in a position of the
universe being canceled how do you
advertise the restart while you're
having Aquaman come out without being
like I don't need to watch it it's not
important I think we need to get away
from this everything is one big thing
concept which has served Marvel but only
Marvel really because I think Star Wars
is better not Skywalker based now
because we've had so much of it I think
the reason the The Mummy Universe didn't
work is because we were overwhelmed with
the idea of these 10 characters being
introduced I think DC should have
different Pockets very consciously well
okay so this kind of ties into the next
part where it says it seems like Gunn
and saffron's priority will be just to
reboot the DC's headlining hero Superman
Wonder Woman Green Lantern and others
while leaving what's currently working
for the studio alone aka the Batman and
the joke universes and potentially guns
work with the Suicide Squad characters
I'm also assuming Peacemaker uh though
we wouldn't be surprised if he wraps up
those characters in season two
[Music]
I oh yeah yeah I guess I I don't know I
kind of think Peacemaker exists in a
world of his own like Peacemaker has
potential if if the DCU does want to
deal with like a a metaverse and like
their own Multiverse you could 100
percent bring John Cena he's that
character is Goofy enough yeah it almost
travels not I mean Deadpool you know
breaks the fourth wall and is his own
specific thing but that character is
like irreverence is on the level of a
Deadpool character I could see them I
don't know I just feel like James Gunn
being in charge he likes or or casting
John Cena as a different per version of
Peacemaker in that world just because
they struck gold with it and it just
seems kind of silly to not do it but
other than that yes I agree uh that and
I was like also they already brought the
Justice League into Peacemaker at the
very end of the season uh Ken's
Redemption says my guess gunwald gun gun
will gun for the release of the rest of
the DC movie slated thus far and reset
the lore with Flashpoint absolutely I
mean I agree with that because they're
already he has made it which I I'm
waiting seeing as believing Blue Beetle
um you can tell me when it's gonna be in
theaters every time and I'm just like I
want to see it actually in theaters and
then I will be like it's coming uh so
it's like yeah bring out Blue Beetle uh
bring out Shazam and then
Shazam and that's what like the that's
why I say you know DC Black Label
universes is shazam's now in a rock and
hard place where it's almost New Mutants
because it's coming out so far from
Black Adam Black Adam ties into it but
doesn't and remember New Mutants got
moved like seven times yeah yeah and
reformatted over and over again scarier
yeah I feel like Shazam they could take
out a lot of this if they have any new
um spider Spider-Man Superman stuff
because in the first movie they just
have that little snippet of Superman and
they can just be like this is any
Superman
um so maybe but once again Henry Cavill
is Superman is such perfect casting it's
a shame to throw that away and he's
ashamed to not like he just had this
coming I think you just if you announce
a reset in the real world and say but
these characters these people are still
playing those characters I mean unless
you are so stubborn we could buy Henry
Cavill as Superman but not but just be
like none of those kind of about
Terminator just was like dark fate was
like Terminator Genesis didn't exist and
none of them after Terminator 2 existed
it's a sequel to that movie like they're
kind of trying to do that with stuff now
and Suicide Squad literally James Gunn
just did it he made a Suicide Squad he's
like I'm Gonna Keep who I want exactly
and the alien franchise right yeah you
know people people watch those trust
your audience it exists now uh I have to
I do have to do one quick apology
apologies to off-screen producer Brandon
who's on-screen host branded in my heart
uh he says he misses one day and he's
off the Rogue Squadron no I didn't I
wanted to make your casting a surprise
but I guess I'll announce it now uh
playing the leader of the Rogue Squadron
Brandon Barrick will be starring as
Brando cool ass man uh
space pirate that joins the Rogue
Squadron and and leads them into battle
with cool catchphrases like we're gonna
need a bigger ship uh a bigger [ __ ]
um also Brandon got me this as a
Christmas gift and oh thank you Brandon
and he got me in every K Ross action
figure which turns into a Doctor Doom
action figure which is crazy he must
have known something oh that doesn't
really do the second part but I might
modify it and um recent Marvel news
Echoes had writer Marion Dyer dare dare
mentioned on the writer's panel podcast
that the show won't be ready until
probably a year from now damn Echo was
originally slated for early summer 2023
mean lucky season 2 will be the Marvel's
second live action show of the year
um a year from now because it's only the
only connection it really cares for me
is Daredevil born again
right so it is not being in Loki is okay
no no no not at all is Daredevil Born
Again part of the MCU yeah yes okay I
you know I realize that seems like an
obvious question but the fact that they
announced it immediately with a 19
episode order I was like oh are they
just doing this as like a separate I
know that like Daredevil's in the MCU
now I guess that was a stupid question
but like it just seems like kind of the
type of thing of like are they trying to
create a separate Daredevil Universe it
is crazy to open it with like here's 23
episodes but we're only gonna give like
every other MCU show like eight or six
yeah I think it's that's the president
of like there are no rules yeah between
the special editions being like 40
minutes and then some show six some
shows eight I like that they're like
Guardians was 36 minutes yeah it was
very weird it was very short yeah
it's like 42 or something but I enjoyed
it you know I I'll be honest you know
with our job we have to often watch
things at midnight yep and sometimes
when the episode is an hour and 12
minutes real hard it's a struggle a
quick 30 six jaunty little holiday
episode uh at midnight felt great and
again how much Freedom did Michael
giaccino and James Gunn have because
they weren't so tied like I obviously
they're gonna have uh ramifications like
the holiday special has a big twist
which will affect three but I didn't
feel a werewolf when I had to be watched
by anyone that had seen any MCU before
and I like that for it uh I just want to
answer this really quick because I
actually don't know Christian
unpronounceable said do any of you find
humanoids know if the Constantine sequel
is still coming and that's the film with
Keanu right so I think that is kind of
establishing the DC Black Label I'm
talking about okay because if you could
do Joker and you can do the Batman you
can do Constantine arguably I think that
James Gunn is probably gonna want
something Guillermo del Toro pursued
dark Justice League for a long time yeah
uh justice league dark sorry um and I I
think that honestly James gotten the
type to Green Light singular movies so I
think that if Constantine Mike Shepard
in like this like trust us it's over
here kind of thing but we don't have
names but we don't have anything that
says it's gone or it's staying no and it
was and they announcement was in a weird
time because they were like everything
except this it dropped and then
literally two days later it was like
we're getting rid of everything right
and I was like but you just announced
this so what what's going on I I do need
to I'm getting a second announcement now
for Rogue Squadron casting I have to be
very clear uh we we do now have to
announce due to leaks the confirmation
that Zach Huddleston has been cast
Squadron is z H2O
futuristic sex Android no not only for
pleasure and to find treasure oh right
he works as a metal detector and uh
something else I can't talk about on air
happy birthday Mom uh wherever you are
uh she ran away a long time ago mom
Sagittarius she went out to get a pack
of cigarettes and never came back I
don't know I don't follow astrology
because I uh I'm too devoutly religious
all right what's the religion you don't
want to know
let's just say John Travolta me and Tom
Cruise
yeah it's true
I'm gonna get those hands on those cans
and then let me do the stress test you
know what I'm saying dog all right
detailed his experience joining the cast
of Multiverse of Madness while also
revealing uh him returning as Reed
Richards is not very likely is it
Jessica he said quote there aren't any
discussions at all the only discussion I
had was actually in the second to last
week of Jack Ryan heard of itchy plug
for his show Kevin feige called and said
would you ever find LA and play in our
sandbox for a day being turned into
spaghetti wasn't my end goal in life as
far as how it goes in the Marvel
Universe but you know it was fun
nonetheless all this to say much like
that quote a lot of that was mailed in
huh all right we've got some Concepts go
ahead no it's okay you keep going I was
just having fun I thought that was more
uh Krasinski news it is uh we got some
concept art for what Sherry may have
looked like in a Chadwick Bozeman LED
black panther 2 artist Phil Saunders
shared this image on his Instagram
saying this was my earliest image for
wakanda forever
this was my earliest image for wakanda
forever painted months before you were
just really happy with that all right
Chadwick boseman's tragic passing during
that period I did another image pairing
re-reassury that everyone loved at the
time it features their pair standing on
a balcony in wakanda Riri and her Proto
prototype MK1 armor taking a selfie with
the princess like a wide-eyed Taurus
while Sherry gives her the grumpy side
eye a reflection of their Rocky start in
the comics this concept art is also an
homage to a panel on the wakandan Run of
Iron Heart oh
can I also say to every single person
that was mad that they thought Riri felt
shoot like shoehorned in she was in the
original draft of Chadwick still I hate
that hole don't start drives me insane
do not that's my least favorite that's
horrible kind of forever I'll say it
well wrong Channel wrong channel to even
start this on because that was my beef
with Eric Boss oh really because I like
I loved that plot line because I said
the first thing I saw on stage with what
kind of forever is like how much they
were a family and the second thing I saw
on stage was how she was exactly
riggered from the comics and I was like
this fits this world so well they tied
it in a really interesting new way and
this shows that even when we had
Chadwick the original draft that was a
completely different movie featured this
Duo which is Sean even he's been written
in the wall forever amen you know amen
baptized me in this Eric left I'm back
yeah now that Eric's ran back to San
Francisco we can say whatever we want
it's in our phase four breakdown of all
the movies I'm not outing anything it's
already out speaking of which uh
speaking of sandboxes I've heard of John
Krasinski to play in my sandbox and he
just took a piss in it anyway it's time
for the break room Barbie one yeah
yeah no I wanted you to say and
[ __ ] Barbie news
BBW I have to get that you didn't see
the pen throw because
Margo Robbins you want to read this one
because this is all you baby
Carrie Mulligan had a very amazing
percent uh sat down for a one-on-one
Mulligan asked Robbie do you make giant
Barbie houses in this film Robbie said
the dream house uh the dream houses
you'll see more dream you'll see some
more dream houses and it will be
everything you ever dreamed of oh I
highly doubt that wait what
then it's not everything I dreamed of
because last night I had a dream that me
and Margot Robbie were playing duck duck
goose together one on one and I kept
losing oh forget the duck at the goose
let's just say
I was both
Richardson
um also the uh the side side note to
this the actors on actors picks were so
interesting and so it was Viola Davis
and Jennifer Lawrence yep it was uh
Austin Butler and Janelle Monae which
was I think the most interesting types
of charm at each other Colin Colin
Farrell and Jamie Lee Curtis Curtis
because Jamie Curtis was like so calm
and chill and Colin Farrell was like
very like excitable at Jamie Lee Curtis
So their energies were so interesting
but they're both such movie stars Carrie
Mulligan and Margot Robbie is such an
interesting pair that I'm like yeah they
do match each other put them together or
something still talking like Elvis oh
yeah come on
it's like Johnny Depp and Hunter
Thompson that's not going away it's
never going away but Janelle Monae I
love that like Smooth off because
they're both so like Smooth oh it was
like a sexy interview and they also do
Adam Sandler and Brendan Fraser Adam
Sandler couldn't say his name but then I
guess Brendan Fraser's name is
pronounced Brendan Fraser
yeah I've heard that no I'm not saying
that
yeah yeah but Brendan yeah but his real
last Guy Fieri's real last name is not
fienna
I think it's it's guy boy no it's not
yeah guy man
guy guy son guy fire oh my God yeah they
were they were good I like the actors
and actors this year they were so
interesting did you guys see the one it
was uh we'll do this every day actors on
Apple promoting uh available today in
HBO Max look at that I saw one with two
porn stars doing actor on actor but they
didn't talk much all right I'm sure they
did there was plenty of yeah yeah yeah
hey hey hey somebody that too hey now
you're an awesome yeah I don't stop yeah
a lot of the porns I watch are called
smashments anyway uh what a title can
you grab me the epic hero or the sorry
new rock stars merchandise here the
holidays are just around the corner just
a hop Skippy and a jumpy uh it's a great
place to find yourself something special
for the nerd in your life at new
rockstars merch.com there's tons of
awesome new rockstars merch to check out
and if you're worried about knowing
someone's size there are size agnostic
merch options for you to choose from
including hats mugs stickers and pins
look at this you take those family
photos of uh The Three Stooges in the
bathtub I don't know probably not this
is probably some there's also four
people it's the bathtub in the White
House is that Taft yeah that's the Taft
tub
oh okay they were very uh intimate back
here's what I want to say screw all
these men for fat shaming Taft uh I'm
gonna say why do they fat shame is my
why use these stickers but you can make
your own new Rockstar's thumbs on your
family photos so sorry uh no no problem
I support the channel buy some merch
check out all the awesome merch options
over at new rockstarsmerch.com uh and
also we want to thank uh a new friend of
the channel and hopefully one that will
continue a long and prosperous
friendship with 100 soft for sending us
these great Mega Emoji vinyl figures
they're emojis in vinyl form it's Alf
and he's in POG form uh okay elf is back
and he said pod form is the quote I
missed him this is the Ms Marvel oh look
how cute she is with her magical Cree
technology Fisk maybe the magic that's a
good Bob and begin
sharp haircut I agree uh also uh I'm not
really good at putting it back they have
enamel pins enamel right I say it right
like the She-Hulk one okay uh if you
want to send us some free stuff we will
certainly give it a good home thank you
100 soft for these Mega emojis and in
that and and
enamel pins I keep calling them vinyl
pins I don't know guys they're great for
gift givers especially in the season and
they also have other things that if your
family is not oh we don't have that much
Marvel stuff we don't know marvel they
have other things they have little donut
keychains they have dumpster fires they
have a lot of cute we are certainly fans
of 100 so I'll find them at 100 soft
thank you and again send us your
products we will put them in our offices
and smile at them and think fondly of
you it's time for mandatory fun yeah
it's the last mandatory fun of the year
wait I don't think that's accurate well
the last question that I'll be hosting
and you know my
[Music]
he has these white boards but I'm not
going to tell you why yet are we missing
a marker were you fidgeting yes
way to read the script and know what we
need
for being an adult
you always call me the kid someone threw
a marker I guess that says a lot about
me because I also joke about marrying
you a lot so let's read into that
psychiatrist now folks it's Avatar week
and that means the self-proclaimed king
of the world James Cameron
okay like we said before difficult
people never get to work again in
Hollywood except for James Cameron
strike 19. I think someone put it best
on Twitter when they were like James
Cameron is Michael Bay with a weaker
Coke problem I'm gonna read you a quote
now
I'm gonna read you guys a quote I like
it uh
it's not that far from the truth the
truth in comedy will set you free I am
going to read you guys a quote and you
need to write down on your board if this
is something James Cameron said in real
life or if this is something a villain
in a James Cameron film set and let me
tell you I love this video everyone so
much it's not gonna be as easy as you
think so we either write IRL or movie
and we don't have to yeah you don't have
to say who first quote I make my own
luck
you got about 10 seconds for each one
do we have erasers anywhere two one
should have thought about yeah I said in
real life if you guys I wrote James
Cameron because I wasn't thinking but in
real life I think it's from a movie too
it is from Titanic
yeah I knew that one okay
uh
who said
oh that was named Cal Hockley
Billy Zane would say something like that
yeah okay but in real life if you set
your goals ridiculously high and it's a
failure you will fail above everyone
else's success God damn that's hurtful
no that's inspiring if you set your
goals ridiculously high and it's a
failure you will fail above everyone
else's successes
that sounds too pretentious to not be
him in real life
IRL all correct so right now Jessica or
uh Wu has
who has won you said you said IRL or it
has one yes all right
I try to live with honor even if it cost
me millions of dollars sorry say it one
more time I try to live with honor even
if it cost me millions of dollars oh my
God I hate that I love how hard I hate
this I just hate it I like this game but
it's tough I hate this three two one I
said movie this is in real life
I try to live with honor even if it
costs me Millions you are such a Liars
I have to okay that's so funny
also so it's still one two one one all
right okay ready what did you want to
make another I was gonna say can I make
a little suggestion sure give us a
little bit time to reveal because the
delay on the chat oh yeah so maybe they
give some times to guess in the chat
sure so you just tell me when I can do
my job man proposes and God disposes
49 God 48 God disposes man proposes man
proposes and God disposes 47.
46
45. I don't know if we need that much
time I think we're good
all right turn it over movie this is in
real life
I said so why does he talk like that
yeah who's just in an interview like I'm
gonna drop this weird bar about my
protection yeah does he pre-write these
before he goes into interviews because
that's not something someone just says
James Cameron more than right now
deal with it there were problems and a
few deaths were involved
it's him searching for the Titanic
two deaths were involved
I said what I said I have the money not
to elaborate yeah I
uh the honor my statement the honor one
really got me I like I I
uh two one
movie
IRL it is in fact a movie
it is in fact a movie
so now it's all tied at two should we do
one more John yeah absolutely one more
really quick
okay all right one more until we have a
winner yeah I'll get it oh yeah
all right this is hard so so hard we all
could lose the snake kills by squeezing
very slowly this is how the Civilized
World slowly slowly pushes into the
forest and takes away the world that
used to be
the snake kills by squeezing very slowly
this is how the Civilized World slowly
slowly pushes into the forest and takes
away the world that used to be he says
such crazy things oh we're doing it you
gotta answer yeah okay I was just gonna
say something oh oh sorry no go no
please say what you were gonna say I
said in real life he did say that
so much of him that's why I'm completely
like yeah he says such crazy things I
like some of his dialogue more than this
movie times
that's what I'm kind of yeah like this
is too good to be in this movie right
and that's like alternator two stuff uh
people call me a perfectionist but I'm
not I'm a rightist I do something until
it's right and then I move on to the
next thing
wait say it again people call me a
perfectionist but I'm not I'm a rightist
I do something until it's right then I
move on to the next thing
well
did he write the rightest lies say it
one more time say one more time people
call me a perfectionist but I'm not I'm
a rightist I do something until it's
right then I move on to the next thing I
just ate if I do I know this is this is
hella tricky one this one's very tricky
and I want to say what three two one I
said movie I said in real life ladies
and gentlemen we have a winner
let me tell you something
and this is a true story and we have a
planning meeting every morning for the
for the break room uh and we supposed to
we're figuring out what version of this
game would be the most fun
the first iteration was who said this
James Cameron or a fascist ruler
we realized with that reaction that was
going too far you don't want to alienate
it's not coming on the record no we just
don't want it we don't want to shine a
light on any fascists on this channel at
all uh except for John he's the only
fascist we allow and his politics are
milding as he gets old Father John Misty
alone yeah
now the second iteration of this was who
said this a cult leader or James Cameron
and by the way that was equally
difficult the third version was a
motivational speaker or James Cameron
but the motivational speeches were too
positive yeah too positive and in the
end the only person who can say crazy
[ __ ] on par with James Cameron are the
people saying the lines written by James
Cameron so for that my friends is how
you land the bird on a mandatory fund
thank you so much I love this what a joy
it's been to do these shows for you all
year what else we got can I ask them
real quick before we move on whose idea
was it to do the IRL or movie
John and Brandon combined it definitely
wasn't mine I'll take no credit for that
during most of the meetings I'm just
taking massive bong reps
my phone died halfway through the memes
and I never came back
um you guys thanks for joining us today
this was our episode of the break room
we're here for the rest of the week and
then you won't see me until my birthday
yeah
um and we're celebrating for your
birthday
we're going to the Moon
[Applause]
because I don't want you to see me but
if you see me you better come up and
give me a gambling tip like put it on
red because I'll do it yeah Reno is
going to be fun yeah I love Reno Tahoe
biggest little city in the world also
everybody that came and said hi at La
Comic-Con it was great yeah I haven't
been back on since like he's feeling a
little better yeah yes we love seeing
everybody we look forward to more cons I
do like seeing you in person even though
I pretend that I don't on this show it
does it does bring me joy to see you
people you guys are so sweet the
holidays
great holiday season be sure to like And
subscribe for the channel and for the
break room and make sure to check us out
I think my video is Easter eggs and
breakdown for across the spider versus
actually just dropped before the break
room new rock stars merch and go ahead
and give 100 soft a visit over on
socials and Order yourself some vinyl
goodness and maybe a pin or two yes look
out for Eric boss's breakdown of the
design for the animation for across the
spider verse mt's breakdown of how the
universes are actually colliding and how
it's going to work can you ever break
down yourself don't you
oh well watch all of Jessica's videos
and face my wrath and then you know just
leave mine and Eric's uh Star Wars Jedi
Survivor uh breakdown in the background
oh yeah while you uh walk your dog or
make love either way wait a minute or
both hey happy New Year everyone happy
holidays and a merry Festival us all
[Music]
all right
foreign